hello everyone and what is up well I'll
tell you what is up the World Junior
Championship is being played currently
in Italy from the 12th of November - I
think 22nd of November or maybe 25th -
but doesn't really matter and young
Prabhu does it again this is a game from
round for the World Junior Championship
he's playing against Jordan van forest
and mr. forest here is seed number one
in this tournament with the highest
rating of twenty six hundred and sixteen
young Prabhu is see number 26 with a
rating of twenty five hundred and nine
so quite a matchup for him and prior to
this round in the first three rounds
they accumulated two and a half points
each so but this is definitely an
important game for both of them and it's
it's quite interesting how the game
plays out like the title suggests that
Prague played a perfect game well to my
to my capabilities and you know my
knowledge this definitely is a perfect
game against the 2600 plus player and
for those of you who enjoy playing the
Italian game and I'm sure it will be
quite instructive so let's see this game
Prague has the white pieces and he plays
efore we have e5 Knight to f3 knight c6
Bishop to c4 Bishop to c5 so detail in
game the one where I like to push B for
now but of course Braga goes castles
Knight to f6 at d3 now d6c 3a6
Bishop to b3 or standard theory if you
enjoy the Italian you're but probably
familiar with all the moves Bishop to a7
now rook to e1 castles we have a ch3 h6
Knight bTW - rookie 8th 9th - f1 Rhema
nuvaring the night - maybe e3 or g3
depends Bishop to e6 offering the
exchange of light square bishops and we
have Bishop to c2 and he doesn't want to
exchange bishops of course this will
this will prove to be a very useful
Bishop as it's IND h7 Square and also
now White is preparing to push d4 so
forest stops this he pushes d5 himself
we have ich after sandy 5/9 capture
sandy v and black is black is okay here
not no problems for him the development
is nice this dark square bishop is is a
very strong piece eyeing that f2 bond
and this is that exactly the reason why
white can't grab the e5 pawn if you
capture the pawn you simply recapture
and after rook captures you have this
unfortunate Bishop captures and I have
to move winning back the pawn black has
a better position now and you can't
recapture the bishop fifteen captures
Queen to f6 check wins the rook on e5 so
after Knight captures on d5 Prager goes
Knights to g3 Queen to d6 night to h4
now preparing moves like Knight to f5
Queen 37 attacking the knight Queen to
h5 a very aggressive idea but I mean why
not now Knight to f5 definitely is an
idea and after DeForest played this will
free the light square Bishop and with
both of these bishops eye on the Kings
side it could be very very you know hard
to play this for black rook a to d8 by
forest and now d4 freeing the bishop we
have nice to f4 Bishop characters on f4
e captures on f4 and knights to f1 and
here we have Queen to f6
because rock d5 for example seems like
an interesting move your attack the
Queen the Queen has to move you win the
night on h4 why not the problem is after
Queen to f3 White has no problems you
can't capture the night if you capture
it Queen captures rook on d5 and you
just lost the exchange of course you
can't capture the Queen if pressure
capture screen rubber captures and this
is checkmate
so after Knight f-14 is to realize is
that I have to move the Queen so Queen
to f6
we have Knight to f3 now getting tonight
away from h4 rocky 7 preparing to double
up rocks and e-file Bishop to b3 Bishop
capture some b3 a capture some b3 and
rugby to e8 so doubling up on
we file night 1 to D two nights to d8
and this is a very interesting very
interesting idea because this night
isn't really doing anything it can't
jump anywhere when Franco played the d4
he completely locked to this dark square
Bishop out of the game
there's no way to activate this bishop
so Jordan's idea is to play Knight to d8
riemann over it and then probably push
c5 at some point to free this Bishop
from a7 so night to the 8th but probably
immediately stops this before so no c5
ideas available here c6 and may be
preparing bishop tbh to at least give
this bishop some activity but Queen to
g4 preparing if now Bishop comes to b8
Queen to see it may be infiltrating with
the Queen is an idea rook captures an e1
Rock captures rook captures Knight
captures soul exchanging both rooks and
now Knight 36 stopping any Queen in
infiltration ideas night the d3 now we
have Queen to g5 forest offers the
exchange of Queens Knight to e4 now
forcing black to capture the Queen Queen
captures H captures and here we have
King to f8 immediately starting to bring
the King into the game and Prague who
does the same King f1 King g7 in g2 and
our g5 okay and what do you play here
knight Knight d2 c5 and this is this is
a great move you're attacking that b7
pawn and black doesn't really have a lot
of options here you can't push the
b-pawn you're losing the a pawn but this
is this is just one one hell of a move
because some some of you might get to
get the idea why would I play Knight c5
and allow black to exchange his useless
bishop for my strong night that can
potentially come to e5 why not the
problem is after Knight to e5 you have
Bishop to b8 now attacking tonight and
okay you do have a knight c4 but now
Knight c7 sorry Bishop c7 and now your
knight doesn't really have anywhere to
go so you just improved the
of this dark square bishop and you
didn't really achieve anything so Prague
definitely goes for the best idea after
g5 he plays Knight d2 c5 attacking the
b7 pawn and he allows the exchange of
course you don't capture with the night
if you capture with the knight Knight
captures still attacking the b7 pawn and
after capture capture this is a
completely winning and game for white
the king is coming D 3 E 4 and the
points will be pushed c4 d5 black can't
stop this so after Knight d2 c5 forest
played Bishop captures and c5 we have B
captors on c5 and Knight to g7 and again
with a much better position for white as
you'll see Knight to d6 and this is very
strong the knight is amazing and b6 is
attacking the b7 pawn and ok this can be
prevented what attacked b5 now of course
you can't capture with Amazon because it
was the knight but it doesn't matter
because this b5 move now we have King to
d3 getting your King into the game kinky
sex kingi for of course h5 and ok h5 f
3h captors on g4 f captures on g4 and
now what do you do here as black the
knight has nowhere to go you can't move
the knight this is covered by the pawn
covered by the pawn covered by the night
so the knight has no jumps if you move
the King anywhere to d7 or eise Evan
you're getting d5 and the white is
breaking through so there are no good
moves you could play a waiting move like
f6 but then you get before and you're
still where you were you know just that
the white position improved so after H
captures in g4 and F captures on g4
Forest played a5 and ok it seems like
maybe black can hold this but not really
this is losing one spot because of night
- b7 now attacking the a5 pawn but not
only attacking the a5 pawn but also
threatening Knights to d8 check and then
forking the c6 pawn and the f7 pawn so
like can't defend both threats
a4 was
night to the eight would check King d7
protecting the c6 pawn but now Knight
captures on f7 so already
Braga grab the pawn now with a
completely winning game night ghost e6
protecting the g5 pawn but here comes
the final blow Knight e5 check attacking
the attacking the c6 pawn and after King
defense King to c7 Braga plays Knight
captures on c6
and black is shattered King captures and
c6 was played and probably just pushed
to d5 for King the king and the night
and this is game over in this position
Jordan and forest resigned the game so
yeah this was around number four Ramesh
Babu pregunta is now three and a half
out of four and if he continues this he
will be the youngest world junior
champion to ever win the World Junior
Championship you know no pressure but
I'm just saying so yeah that's the game
I do hope you enjoyed it especially
those of you who enjoy following the
progress of young Fraggle as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
I would like to thank Tony more what
guitar and Steven Miller for your
contribution to my channel thanks a lot
- really appreciate it thank you for
watching and I will see you soon